el concepto de concavidad es súper
importante y te lo vas a encontrar a
cada rato en tus clases entonces lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo con cada
habilidad es número uno hablar acerca de
concavidad de cóncavo hacia arriba y de
cóncavo hacia abajo eso nos va a dar más
o menos una intuición de qué quieren
decir estos términos y número dos quiero
hablar de puntos de inflexión estos
simplemente son puntos de transición
donde se pasa de ser cóncavo hacia
arriba a cóncavo hacia abajo o bien
viceversa entonces vamos a hablar de las
siguientes dos ideas la primera es ser
cóncavo hacia arriba déjalo escribo por
aquí cóncavo hacia arriba eso lo voy a
escribir aquí a la izquierda y en color
rosa a la derecha voy a poner cóncavo
hacia abajo cóncavo hacia abajo sale
pasemos a cóncavo hacia arriba de una
manera muy sencilla para pensar acerca
de cóncavo hacia arriba es que la
gráfica de la función tiene forma de v
por eso se llama cóncavo hacia arriba
déjame hacer un dibujo pero pues deja de
pintar unos ejes verdad para que me
creas que estoy graficando algo y no
simplemente dibujando una entonces si
así se ven los ejes
la gráfica de una función cóncava hacia
arriba se vería más o menos así déjame
ponerlo con el mismo color verde se
vería algo de este estilo la gráfica se
extiende verdad sigue yendo hacia la
derecha si x es positivo o hacia la
izquierda si x es negativo pero bueno en
todo el dominio de esta función digamos
ftx es cóncava hacia arriba porque justo
tiene esta forma de eeuu en un momento
voy a discutir qué tiene que ver esto
con la derivada o sea vamos a ver una
condición algebraica para concavidad
mientras esta es una forma de
identificarla de manera visual va de
manera similar vamos a ver qué quiere
decir que algo sea cóncavo hacia abajo
voy a volver a pintar el plano x si
simplemente estoy dando ejemplos
arbitrarios por ejemplo aquí pues el
mínimo no tuvo por qué haber quedado en
el primer cuadrante ni nada lo único que
me importa es que tenga forma de un
ahora vámonos a cóncavo hacia abajo a lo
mejor ya adivinaste como es si éste es
hacia arriba cóncavo hacia abajo va a
ser al revés o sea va a verse más o
menos así ok le voy a llamar gdx
ahora nos pasa lo siguiente en todo el
dominio la gráfica tiene forma de una
volteada y por tanto la función es
cóncava hacia abajo va entonces ya
tenemos una forma de así a simple vista
poder identificar si una función es
cóncava hacia arriba o cóncava hacia
abajo pero ahora vamos a hablar acerca
de las pendientes vamos a hacer un
análisis visual aquí a la izquierda
entonces tomemos este punto en ese punto
la pendiente de la recta tangente o sea
de la recta tangente a la gráfica de la
función se ve a ver lo voy a poner un
poco más bonito se vería así eso de ahí
es la recta tangente entonces conforme
movemos x bueno aquí tenemos un cierto
valor de x verdad la pendiente se ve así
es muy negativa ahora conforme
aumentamos x ahora cada que sucede
entonces la aquí la recta tangente se ve
así algo de este estilo observa que
sigue siendo una pendiente negativa
verdad sin embargo ahora es menos
negativa a qué me refiero con esto pues
antes teníamos una pendiente muy
pronunciada pero ahora es un poco menos
pronunciada vamos a seguir con esto sí
no
a este punto de acá todavía tenemos una
pendiente negativa verdad la función va
hacia abajo pero es menos pronunciada y
eso sigue y sigue pasando y cada vez se
vuelve menos y menos pronunciada hasta
que llegamos a este punto de acá este de
aquí es un mínimo y ya habíamos visto
antes que aquí la pendiente se hace cero
qué sucede si seguimos por acá la
pendiente crece va o sea fíjate como la
pendiente va creciendo y creciendo
si seguimos aumentando la equis acá
tenemos otra pendiente que ahora es
positiva pero ahora está más pronunciada
y al parecer la pendiente se va
pronunciando más y más positivamente
entonces aunque aquí tengamos una
pendiente muy pronunciada y negativa y
aquí una pendiente pronunciada positiva
pues todo el tiempo conforme x aumenta
lo voy a poner aquí
conforme x aumenta que le sucede a la
pendiente a pues la pendiente también
estaba incrementando entonces déjame
ponerlo por aquí la pendiente aumenta
saleh y justo esto es la definición de
que algo sea cóncavo hacia arriba en
términos de la derivada de la función o
sea lo que estamos diciendo es que para
que algo sea cóncavo hacia arriba su
pendiente tiene que ir aumentando verdad
aquí fíjate cómo va aumentando aquí
teníamos algo muy negativo menos
negativo aquí estábamos en cero pero
bueno cero le gana a cualquier cosa
negativa luego nos volvimos positivos
más positivos y cada vez más y más
positivos entonces todo el tiempo la
pendiente estuvo aumentando vamos a la
derecha para platicar qué pasa con
cóncavo hacia abajo tomemos una equis
por aquí aquí tenemos una pendiente muy
alta es una pendiente positiva y muy
pronunciada la función va hacia arriba
muy rápidamente
ahora si movemos tantito x digamos por
aquí todavía tenemos una pendiente
positiva pero menos pronunciada eso
quiere decir que la pendiente ha
disminuido aquí la pendiente vuelve a
disminuir observa que el eje sigue
siendo creciente pero cada vez menos y
luego qué sucede qué sucede cuando
llegamos a este punto
del mismo modo que en la izquierda aquí
llegamos a un máximo y como es un punto
crítico la pendiente está así planeta
planeta planeta bueno luego si seguimos
hacia la derecha la pendiente se empieza
a ser negativa más negativa y cada vez
más y más negativa entonces conforme
vamos moviendo x lo voy a poner aquí
x aumenta entonces en esta curva la
pendiente disminuye verdad la pendiente
disminuye y sale déjame repetirlo al
principio la pendiente era muy positiva
después conforme fuimos moviéndonos a la
derecha la pendiente fue disminuyendo se
volvió menos y menos positiva hasta que
llegó a cero y luego se hizo poco
negativa y luego muy negativa la
pendiente disminuye en cóncavo hacia
arriba pasamos de negativo a positivo la
pendiente aumenta
sale ahora voy a hacer un ejemplo que
tenga la combinación de ambas voy a
dejar esto por aquí para que ahorita lo
veamos como referencia y déjame dibujar
unos ejes por ahí está un eje x
no quedaron muy derechitos pero bueno
funciona para lo que queremos y voy a
dibujar una curva pues algo de este
estilo
bar
sale entonces en qué intervalo del
dominio de esta función
digamos hdx tenemos que las funciones
cóncava hacia arriba o con capacidad
bueno ya platicamos de cómo poder
determinar esto a simple vista en
cóncavo hacia arriba se ve con forma de
eeuu y en cóncavo hacia abajo se ve como
una pues como una volteada pues entonces
por aquí digamos más o menos en este
punto verdad de aquí en adelante tenemos
esta función esta gráfica en forma de un
entonces de aquí en adelante
tenemos que la función es déjame
escribir lo mejor por acá entonces en
ese intervalo
es cóncava
hacia arriba vale ahora vamos a ver qué
sucede en el intervalo hacia atrás es
decir de este punto para atrás en esta
parte aquí tenemos que es cóncava hacia
abajo con un cava hacia abajo otra vez
esto es así simplemente visualmente pero
vamos a explorar qué pasa con la
pendiente mira déjame hacerlo con otro
color
aquí la recta tangente tiene una
pendiente positiva y muy alta se vuelve
cada vez menos positiva aquí se va a
cero luego empieza a disminuir verdad se
hace un poquito negativa más negativa se
hace más y más negativa entonces en todo
este intervalo hasta el punto que
marcamos la pendiente
decreciente lo cual es consistente con
lo que dijimos que era ser cóncavo hacia
abajo pero algo interesante pasa aquí
verdad en este punto de aquí a lo mejor
no estoy siendo muy preciso pero bueno
más o menos en ese punto la pendiente se
ve así es más negativa que en valores
anteriores lo cual indica que iba
disminuyendo pero en el punto que
marcamos pasa algo interesante de
repente la pendiente empieza a crecer a
ver déjame pintarlo un poco más bonito
para que quede el dibujo bien padre
entonces déjame pintar que la pendiente
se veía más bien así vale entonces bueno
empecemos por cómo venía si veníamos de
la izquierda es decir de este punto
hacia la izquierda
teníamos que en las x anteriores había
una pendiente menos negativa entonces la
pendiente iba disminuyendo pero de
repente este comportamiento cambia la
pendiente se hace menos negativa luego
se hace 0 luego se hace un poco positiva
y luego más positiva entonces en todo el
intervalo que estaba atrás de este punto
nuestra pendiente era decreciente hasta
que llegamos
este punto de aquí y después de ese
punto nuestra pendiente es creciente
aquí cambia verdad cambian las cosas
entonces este punto debería de tener
algún nombre especial y bueno de hecho
existe un nombre especial para este
punto de aquí en el cual cambiamos de
concavidad va entonces este punto le
llamamos punto de inflexión le voy a
poner aquí punto de inflexión va y ojo
también se vale si tenemos el cambio de
concavidad al revés es decir si
empezamos con algo que es cóncavo hacia
abajo y luego cóncavo hacia arriba
entonces el punto en el cual se cambia
el tipo de concavidad digamos este de
aquí es esencialmente donde la uv se
voltea verdad o sea teníamos una u y se
voltea de cabeza ese es el punto de
inflexión sale espero que al menos
visualmente ya entendamos que es la
concavidad hacia abajo hacia arriba y
los puntos de inflexión pero ahora vamos
a pasar al álgebra hablaremos en
términos de la segunda derivada de la
función
entonces la derivada déjame mejor
escribirlo a ver voy a ir acá abajo
entonces fx
la función es la función y eso es lo que
hemos estado graficando efe prima de x
es la pendiente de la función la
pendiente de pues en el punto x verdad
es la pendiente de la función
y qué es efe doble prima de x pues ese
doble prima es la derivada de la primera
derivada entonces esa es la pendiente de
la pendiente o bien la razón de cambio
razón de cambio d
pendiente va entonces cómo podemos decir
esto de cóncavo hacia arriba y cóncavo
hacia abajo en términos de la segunda
derivada pues mira acá la pendiente
comenzó siendo negativa y poco a poco se
volvió positiva la pendiente va
creciendo y por tanto f doble prima de x
efe doble prima de x es mayor que 0
porque pues justo cuando esto pasa
cuando ese doble prima de x es mayor que
0 entonces eso quiere decir que la razón
de cambio de la pendiente es positiva y
eso es justo lo que quiere decir que
algo sea cóncavo hacia arriba ahora en
cóncavo hacia abajo la pendiente va
decreciendo
es decir la razón de cambio de la
pendiente es negativa de este modo f
doble prima en x debe de ser menor que
cero más lo pongo aquí en un cuadrito y
entonces en la situación cuando
cambiamos fíjate vamos a esta situación
aquí estábamos en cóncavo hacia abajo
estamos cóncavo hacia abajo en este
intervalo lo cual quiere decir que la
segunda derivada debe de ser menor que
cero verdad en este intervalo la razón
de cambio de la pendiente
es negativa va disminuyendo entonces en
este intervalo nuestra segunda derivada
es menor que 0 pero luego se vuelve
cóncava hacia arriba entonces la segunda
derivada debe ser mayor que 0 en este
intervalo asumiendo que la segunda
derivada fuera continua en este punto
debemos tener que f doble prima de x es
igual a 0 en otros vídeos voy a hacer
algunos ejemplos
esta condición no es suficiente para
garantizar que tenemos un punto de
inflexión para deberás verificar que
tenemos un punto de inflexión hay que
checar que la segunda derivada cambie de
signo otra vez si la función pasa de
cóncava hacia abajo a cóncava hacia
arriba o viceversa entonces el signo de
la segunda derivada cambia y por tanto
en algún punto debe de ser igual a cero
pero si la segunda derivada es igual a
cero puede que tengamos un punto de
inflexión y para verificarlo hay que ver
que la segunda derivada realmente cambie
de signo veremos un ejemplo de esto en
el siguiente vídeo por el momento espero
que hayas agarrado la intuición de
concavidad y de que tiene que ver con la
segunda derivada otra vez si la
pendiente va creciendo entonces la razón
de cambio de la pendiente es positiva y
entonces la segunda derivada es positiva
y viceversa si la pendiente va
disminuyendo entonces la razón de cambio
es negativa entonces la segunda derivada
es menor que 0 a un punto en el cual se
cambia la concavidad es decir donde la
segunda derivada cambia de positiva a
negativa o viceversa le llamamos un
punto d
lección